if you love movies you've probably heard
of akira kurosawa many times if your
film appreciation journey is still young
however you might not realize just how
many of your favorite films have been
inspired by Kurosawa's works George
Lucas was heavily inspired by the hidden
fortress while making Star Wars even
Seven Samurai his personal favorite of
Kurosawa's used white transitions
something Lucas did often in every Star
Wars film the true genius of Kurosawa I
think and tell you've seen a few of the
films and then you've been able to see
other films at the same time and be able
to realize his visual style but my
favorite of all time is really Seven
Samurai Sergio Leone's A Fistful of
Dollars was an unsanctioned remake of
your Jimbo and of course the Magnificent
Seven is a loose remake of Seven Samurai
let me say it simply I mean Kurosawa was
my master and so many others the master
of so many other filmmakers over the
years I set among generations of
filmmakers and film lovers and watched
those astonishing visions he was able to
conjure up his imagination and
completely rendered them on the screen
and there's plenty more but Kurosawa's
influence and the techniques that he
used especially in Seven Samurai have
been felt far beyond just remakes or
retellings of his films today's action
epics
and action films in general Oh
everything to Kurosawa and specifically
Seven Samurai
just like the good the bad and the ugly
shaped the modern Western and we cannot
escape the shadow of the good the bad
and the ugly whenever we watch a Western
we are still feeling the impact of Seven
Samurai today which is arguably
Kurosawa's most known film and while I
do love you Jimbo and Rashomon this
influential 1954 classic is my personal
favorite and people have been talking
about Seven Samurai for decades there's
very few new things that I can bring to
the table so the best that I can do is
try to appeal to the audience that I
have I know a lot of you are hardcore
film lovers and a lot of you have seen
Seven Samurai and tons of other classic
films I know a lot of you study film go
to college but I also know that I have a
large demographic of people who are
younger who've never experienced films
like these before
and it can be a little daunting for one
thing it's three hours and 27 minutes
long it's also black and white and it's
subtitled these are all very scary
things to people who are just starting
their film appreciation journey but I'm
here to reassure you Seven Samurai is
one of the best films ever made
for a reason the conversation that
surrounded Kurosawa for years revolves
around heaps of praise and appreciation
for all he did for film but what's often
glossed over and forgotten while
reflecting on his work was his prowess
as an entertainer this film is
delightful dare I say even a little
heartwarming it's message about building
people up rather than tearing them down
is going to be timely forever and it's a
film that doesn't feel like it's a task
to watch even though it has such a long
runtime and if you're new to Cora Sabo
you may be thinking you're getting into
something difficult I remember the first
time I watched films like these in my
teenage years I remember those times and
some of the films I'm going to be
talking about this year in my pre-1970
series are those films that I discovered
and that helped me boost my appreciation
for film but there's anxiety and there's
also elation simultaneously about these
films because you might be concerned
what if I don't like this film that
everyone says is so good but at the same
time you're about to watch a film with
fresh eyes that's considered a classic
and it's exciting within the first 15
minutes you know you're in the hands of
a master there's been much discussion
about Kurosawa's brilliant framing and
especially the way he uses movement
definitely check out the channel every
frame a painting which sadly is no
longer producing content they made a
really great video about the way Akira
Kurosawa uses movement in his films
nearly every shot in Seven Samurai is
filled with depth with characters
standing near us movement behind them
and great distance visible in the frame
something is always moving and shifting
in and out of frame it's absolutely
stunning this also has one of my
favorite characters ever in any movie
that of kikuchiyo played by Toshiro
Mifune the legendary actor his
performance is infused with physicality
tragedy and even slapstick one shot of
him jumping down a steep hill without a
single hint of fear shows his dedication
to the role his attempts to prove
himself to the other samurai are
endearing never annoying his seems
scolding the samurai about their
treatment of the farmers is a real
highlight as well as the eventual reveal
about his characters past and part of me
is always wondered if akira toriyama was
ever inspired by this character while he
crafted goku for his manga Dragonball
because the character of kikuchiyo is
extremely similar in a lot of ways he's
very optimistic he's a little bit of a
klutz but at the same time he's very
excited about battle he's often hopping
up and being very physical just like
Goku is when he knows he's about to get
in a fight and I'm curious just how much
inspiration he drew from this character
while literally drawing Goku Takashi
Shimada is also a highlight as the
loving leader of the samurai his firm
resolve regarding saving others in
battle and thus saving yourself is one
of the touching messages behind Kurosawa
film and while we watching this movie to
prepare for this review it's very
obvious that a film like this would not
be around today it would be shaved by an
hour at least with relevant character
drama removed in favor of action
sequences gratefully The Criterion
blu-ray actually preserves the
intermission which by the way there's
something inherently beautiful about an
intermission it's tough to explain I
think it has to do with the fact that
you're given this period to breathe
about what you just saw and reflect on
what it means for the characters
something else that Kurosawa understands
very well and particularly in this film
is the use of character perspective a
point of view that he turns to most
often is the youngest of them all who
falls for one of the women in the
village through his eyes we experienced
the first initial horrors of war for
instance in a scene with three Scouts we
see it play out
his perspective and we get nervous
because he's getting nervous the point
of view that Kurosawa chooses highlights
the feeling he wants the audience to
have I think it's one of the reasons
Monet is so incredible we often see him
from the point of view of the other
samurai because they think he's a bit of
an oddball but in the moments where his
character is given the opportunity to
take over the whole frame he lets his
real self out and it's captivating
the battle sequences are still absorbing
today and it shows just how observant
Kurosawa was with his immaculate framing
and I've always felt sorry for some of
the stuntmen particularly this guy
because that shit looks genuinely
painful if you've never seen this film
there's a reason you've heard about it
countless times its Reach is
unparalleled in our modern cinematic
landscape and if you're about to watch
it for the first time I envy you I'm
gonna give Seven Samurai and a plus guys
thank you so much for continuing to
watch this series of pre-1970s reviews
I'm honestly having a blast doing this
I'm thinking about continuing it beyond
2018 because I feel like it's just
important that people are discovering
films like this and watching them
because it's really easy for us as film
lovers especially people my age to
assume that everyone's seen these films
already but there's tons of people every
day who are experiencing films like this
who are discovering films like this go
or maybe apprehensive about putting in a
film like this because like I said it's
black and white it's very long it's
subtitled we need to encourage these
types of films more often guys thank you
so much as always for watching if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]